you're gonna have a good time tonight
[Music]
okay
[Music]
two
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
by the way
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no you're never gonna finish
[Music]
[Music]
your videos
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to moses and
friends this is
uh one of our favorite shows to do
because we take all of our favorite
people
the common world we put them up live in
your living room
i am your host moses storm because it is
convenient to have
someone who has the same name as the
show to do it works out for taxes so my
next guest
is our first musician on the show i'm
excited to talk to him not only is he
one of the most
creative rappers out there pretty
successful online
he's got a show called thrift hall
please welcome
houston's native son fat tony yee
man that just feels cool to say what's
up it's just nice to have someone with a
cool name on
hey man somebody had to do it you had to
have a fat [ __ ] on here sooner
or later
so for people that are not familiar with
you and they don't know your stuff
i'm interested in how musicians start
out because i think for comedians you're
usually talking to
friends and then they tell you that hey
you should do this but how
how did you start what was the moment
that made you want to pursue music
well i decided to start at probably the
worst time possible to link up with my
friends it was the summer time
in high school my sophomore year of high
school i decided you know what i'm gonna
put on a punk show
i found this band from new jersey called
the ergs
i emailed them and i said hey i see
y'all on tour
but y'all aren't playing houston let me
book your houston show
they said yes i had no idea what the
[ __ ] i was doing
i had never been to a concert i had
gotten one
flyer in my life from a kid before
but i figured it's like the movies you
go to kinkos you make a flyer xerox it
i found my student directory i mailed
the flyer out to like a hundred kids
five kids show mail like actually
physical mail sticking stamps
freaking the [ __ ] out of them too
licking the [ __ ] out of every one of
them
whole envelopes soaking wet five kids
came to the show but that was really my
start and from there i kept putting on
shows and started making music and just
kind of like
diving right into it that's so cool
because it's not like you just there's
there's two types of hustle where you're
just bothering people to get on their
show
and then it sounds like what you did is
you made your own thing you're like
here's a venue which a lot of people
don't want to do that heavy lifting they
think it's just gonna happen
yeah honestly i didn't know better
because i didn't know anybody else
putting on shows
i'm a teenager and i was really into
uh like 80s punk music and i was really
into this band minor threat and i
saw them and i was like yo these kids
are about my age
and they're putting on shows they're
putting out their own records
you know what i mean i'm like why can't
i do that for me and my friends
whether we're a punk band or not so i
just kind of thought that that's what
you do in music
until later but it worked out because i
learned all these different roles
before i met the people who could
actually do them
yeah it also helps not getting [ __ ]
over in the future because like no i
know what it costs i know
how much drink tickets are going out and
what the door cut is true
no true you just have more agency over
your career
i remember i got like three hundred
dollars at a show
and i was losing my mind inside i was
like yo let's
go to wendy's let's [ __ ] let's let's
do it all 300
is the most amount of no money oh
certainly but performing
just getting that first thing where like
you're not paying to perform
it it's the it's the most amount of
money you'll ever have of like
wow you get a job 16 right
i'm 16 years old with 300 i'm a [ __ ]
baller
what is the wendy's order you go in with
three me me i was the type of guy back
then
who i'd buy everybody [ __ ] like me and
my whole crew i'm buying everybody's
food my personal go-to
just the fries and a frosty dip that
[ __ ] in that's all you need you
don't even need to look at
the chicken nuggets and burgers it's
garbage square burgers get out of here
frosty getting frosty bottle service at
wendy's
corner booth 300.
yeah that money goes quick but that was
the first
the first money is pretty like the
incentive to like okay keep going this
can work out now
is that something you carry over to this
day is to start
really carving out your own lane and
making your own opportunities even as
you get more success
do you still feel that that urge today
definitely because i think that like
you know i feel like in any creative
business
people want to work with their friends
right so no matter
who your agents are your label is
whatever it really is about the person
to person
i get more [ __ ] popping by just talking
to people
befriending people you know and and not
just
artists but anybody that could work in
music or in
show business and a lot of times some of
my best work happens like that like with
thrift haul that was just a friend
who i was introduced to through another
friend and we just hit it off you know
it wasn't like
me going around shopping or looking for
an opportunity it just kind of happened
naturally
and those are the best ones that is a
cool show we should talk about
so thrift haul you would have and
correct me if i'm wrong
you'd bring on musicians like billy
eilish was on one
actors rosario dawson and they basically
it's like a competitive thrift store
show where you gotta
come up with basically the freshest
outfit you know something that's fun
like
i wanted it to be once once we got the
show right which is hard enough to get
something out there even a web series
right once we got it going
it was just like let me just holler at
people i know
and people i kind of know and just see
what happens like
billy eilish total whim i was at my
friend's studio cuckoo
and billy eilish happened to be there i
was talking to cuco's manager
asking about having him on the program
and she was like yo
uh let me text him oh he just texts back
yo he's down to do it but can billy
eilish come too i'm like
yeah absolutely of course but that's how
many of the bookings went on that show
it was like hitting up a person them
wanting to bring their friend on because
because the concept is so loose and it's
and it's the kind of show where you can
just
lean back and have fun and in a way
that's kind of different than like
a normal interview or even playing a
real game show like
the stakes were [ __ ] low we were just
there being silly
you're you're shopping for clothes that
people have probably died in
yes it couldn't be lower we actually
filmed it in a goodwill
while people were shopping so it was
like
the goodwill crowd is not like a macy's
crowd they almost don't
give a [ __ ] if anything just like get
out of the way
it's a little more hostile because
there's not another item out there
so people go through racks so fast in
the goodwill
no one cared that we were no seriously
nobody gave a [ __ ] about us people would
like
yell at us customers would be like can
you get out the way we're like thinking
like oh they're gonna bug out
our talent nobody cared we're in l.a
nobody gives a [ __ ]
would you feel do you think the show
could come back now
in a post pandemic you think people
would be sketched out
now and you know what a world where
people are like
i don't know about these clothes why are
why are these clothes free
we're gonna really have to sanitize it
for the
future episodes you know what i mean
we're gonna have to do a totally
different approach
this shirt you're wearing this this is a
thrift line yes
this is definitely a thrift find 1996
toriyama shirt
recovering christian yeah and get a
good look at this bad boy
it's great but
unfortunately this is one of those
expensive ass vintage t-shirts this this
this ain't no goodwill fine you know
what i mean
but is this the favorite vintage item
definitely hands down
because it's just like it's the kind of
shirt
that has never gotten old for me walking
around with recovering christian biggest
day
get some good looks spark some good
conversations you know what i mean
you cut through all the [ __ ] right
away there's no uh the weather is weird
today
i want to know you what happened you're
advertising your recovery
this is my favorite thrift find i got
two in preparation for this
uh a terrible shirt okay that is very
awful
we have a polka dot shirt and then
probably this something i wear all the
time
it's like a motocross jacket and
favorite thrift find because on it it's
got a
real story because it's barb so it's a
woman's jacket because that's my frame
and it's is not the mama
wow so she that is [ __ ] ill whoever
barb was
really wanted to get it out there that
she was not the mama
it's like some billie jean [ __ ] man it
ain't her it ain't hurt
it ain't her kid don't leave the
responsibilities on her this is what you
can't find at asos
vendetta in a jacket now i think about
it there's a lot of moms out there
taking some [ __ ] they don't need
yeah and i and i and i think we need to
franchise
not the mama into a uh brand i'm on my
business [ __ ]
moses you and i need to do this okay
okay i like this her mom's are tired of
playing the mom roles mm-hmm you know i
can be more like a dad where they leave
at six in the morning don't come back
till 8 42 at night and you're not
allowed to ask questions where they work
that's the kind of father i've always
wanted to be that's the kind of father i
plan to be
and i hope i inspire my wife to become
one of those not the mamas
these uh desert shows you've been
dealing with are pretty cool you're
performing in the desert because
it's the only option essentially it's
always safe
i don't wonder why i just wake up and i
wipe the crust from my eye
she just wake up hope to get the kid to
school on time
it's easy no one's no one's there you
know and when i first did it i was
thinking yo are people or like neighbors
houses some somewhere around here gonna
be tripping nobody gave a [ __ ]
it's just me the nearest house is like
miles and miles away
yeah so you just go there and you set up
like you're there's no permission needed
or permits you just
find a spot exactly it's all wireless we
got in-ears
you know it's very little
and we just make it work no one cares
just find an empty spot i mean i feel
like the worst thing i got to worry
about is like somebody running up on us
maybe trying to rob us [ __ ] with us you
know what i mean
i think it's joshua tree so it's like
where white people go to feel spiritual
so you might get some dudes that look
like me on shrooms
very confused and think that you are an
hallucination
wearing big hats you can't forget the
big hats oh
the giant giant hat that fills in
all the gaps you don't have in your
personality
ask me about my hat because everything
else in my life has been pretty easy
i think that's all you got to worry
about is people coming down from
ayahuasca
coming out of their airbnb dripping you
know what i
might be right there with them we were
very tempted to
take mushrooms doing this because we're
in the desert and typically that's what
we're going to do if we're out there
anyway
you know what i mean yeah the first time
i went to joshua
tree i was like i don't get this [ __ ] at
all and then
with for eric andre's birthday where
mushrooms
yeah and i was like oh i get it i get it
it's not a drug free place
you know even the locals yeah joshua
tree's not beautiful
is i think the message i'm trying to put
out for this show
to get us demonetized
this is great talking to you i can't
believe we're already out of time you
got to come back
because there's so much to talk about
and if if you're down you should do a
song on the show sometime
we'll find a way to set it up i would
love to come sing that would be great
we'll do it we got [ __ ] here
as you can see we have keyboards and we
got boots baby
that's right i'm [ __ ] texting damn
boots okay man this is great so where
people can check you out i think across
social media it's fat tony rap get on
spotify
listen to the new fat tony album exotica
check out the gamma man mariachi remix
because it's lush and beautiful and
hit me up on instagram and [ __ ] i'm
everywhere fat tony everyone this is
great man i'll talk to you soon
love ya bye and then mary you still
standing by
hi hi thank you so
much no it was interesting i
i love hearing about the moms in the
rap audience right finally something we
could relate to i feel like a mom
at any rap show yeah right i always feel
like a mom nowadays i have i'm not mom
are we started are we interviewing yeah
i'll say my next guest
you know are from ponies you've got some
great sets on there
also from solar opposite on hulu mary
mack
thank you for being here hi moses thanks
for having me
it's nice to be here i'm in uh
minneapolis
this summer i was mostly staying in a
camper up in
northern wisconsin in the in the real
woods and um
i did not uh i showered in a lake and
that was
that was um every day i write running
water
in my gratitude journal that's great
because yeah it's not so much showering
in a lake as just
soaking in filthier water what
not joking we lived in a camper for the
first uh
10 years of my life yeah
wow we could probably swap tips
[Music]
we could swap tips where do you empty
the septic tank are you going with the
blue one
do you want a compostable system because
those things never work
i know i've gone through all that you
know what i do
i keep i had to i had to google the
instructions i
i don't know if i should look at the
camera at you but i need to google this
we want you look at the corner of your
room if you look at the back corner of
your room
your eye line could be yeah if you could
completely turn yourself it's just more
engaging
google the instructions on this european
sani party
that came with my camper i was very
complicated and i caught a lot of people
um
talk about the walk of shame um yeah my
walk of shame
is when i like walk into a wayside rest
to empty my camper um my portable camper
toilet
because everyone knows what that is they
make them blue
so everyone's like oh there's all your
feces that's your box of feces
your sani potty was blue i saw a guy get
in a fight with someone at a campground
while he was holding his septic tank he
just emptied it
and it's like well you you lose whatever
you're saying oh yeah i hope
you put some respect on my name oh you
it's like you
you have a box yeah yeah you're you just
you could it's a lot it's a real
exclamation point on whatever you're
saying
is when you release your own human
excrement out of
a receptacle okay yes
in case you didn't know what to talk
about i i
brought a list of possible topics
self learning moses i'm not for it
uh i i'm the kind of person who's like
just put your head down and shut up and
do your work
but you know you know what the pandemic
has done for people
too much self-realization okay
i learned about myself that the greatest
sense of accomplishment
i can ever feel is when i'm almost done
with a bar of soap wow
yeah yeah you can see what you've
accomplished you're like oh
all that showering is paying off and and
it's like
why do i get so excited it's not like
you can cross it off the list moses you
can't be like done showering
um but i get so excited because i never
i've been on the road for 18 years like
i never
get to finish a bar of soap but thanks
to donald trump
and this great pandemic of ours uh i
look at how good i'm doing look how thin
these are oh you brought it oh
i brought it you never see them that
thin in 18 years i've never finished a
bar of soap
and i because i'm always gone and look
at how good i'm doing like
look at how look at look at this
no hair thank god this i think i think
you need to rebrand and you need to sell
thin soap for people that need
accomplishments in their life
yeah like the training wheel of soap
absolutely you get that thin you get
that accomplishment you're welcome
america
if we're lucky we'll have at least six
more months of pandemic so i can finish
these soaps
yeah okay moses do you have a superpower
no i have no super power well i do
what is it is your boss conan o'brien
yeah since you're working for team coco
yeah
okay so guess what when i wake up in the
morning i don't even have to do anything
in my hair i took i got it on my phone
my hair
is as good as conan o'brien's as soon as
i get up
you see that air that's my hair in the
morning
it looks look at that height that
perfect
swoop what's the secret for waking up
with good hair sleep hard
sleep hard have stress dreams sleep hard
nightmares
the sweat and anxiety will exfoliate
follicle
oh sure sweat anxiety dog hair
you want it all in there and then it
help it gives it a little
extra lift before you move on the last
business idea you didn't ask for this
but
the superpower for the hair you have a
salon that's just nothing but twin beds
people lay in the salon and then they
wake up with great hair
that is a good idea you know what though
what if you did a little helper and you
were like
i'll do their hair while they're
sleeping well isn't that a time
saver and a multi-billion dollar idea
i think only you could get away with
that business i think that
um the smaller you are and the quieter
you are at night since they're sleeping
um the better you the more success
you'll have
and if you know a little bit about hair
or if you have a battery operated
currently now you're not a
big big help you don't know where their
outlets are moses
you don't know if they got an outlet
behind the bed what if they only have a
usb
charger and you weren't prepared for
that with your curling iron right
to-do list for conan if you could let
him know
and if you could let ruthie and jp who
elsa work there know
the last time i was on conan they blew
up my cd album
my last cd i have a different cd album
out
but this one they blew it up and then
what happened was
conan and andy signed it very nicely
but then i stored it in some plastic in
a in a closet in los angeles when i was
out there
and this is the kind of air quality in
la you guys
it just ate it's just the acid of either
the plastic or the air just
chewed it away like this is not supposed
to be there
and and they did a nice job took a lot
of time to sign it
and now it's just looks like hell and i
i really would like it if
if they could find it in their busy
schedules if i could
send them this and they could recreate
it maybe
would try to be as authentic as they
were the first time because i would like
to put on my wall but you want the same
message on there the same heartfelt
message
but a redo
i will pay the postage here
i apologize if my conversation is a
little too mundane
i'm enjoying this it's the small things
in life
that you got to think about moses like
in this time of impending doom
and um wretchedness and
it just uh putridity you have to just
focus on what you can control the small
things
right like like who the [ __ ] is using
metal spatulas
on my teflon pants
who's who's doing it is it dogs
my husband's the only one that lives
here get that
mistake this was a huge mistake you
better
you better not be using that on a
nonstick pan
i i cook everything on a paper plate
over the stove i have a very bad life
and i have a can of beans like dennis
the menace
i hope so but this is the worst purchase
i made in
quarantine hands down this has ruined my
life
i got cut on this too this these should
not exist and i think this we need to
rail against these
all these are good for is picking up
that last little bit of soap
yeah right well you know what else
that's good for
drywall you can mud with that you can
mud with that
so yes i'll drywall myself a new pan
is there a quarantine purchase you made
that you regret or are
absolutely love no
i don't know i i can't remember all the
purchases i've been doing a lot of
facebook marketplace
uh mostly for companionship like i don't
need
uh oh you just want to get to know
someone via like i don't even want
an oscillating fan i did buy an
oscillating fan
i even bought a ceiling fan i didn't
need it i just was like
i need to meet somebody i need to see a
person
so like the driveway exchange is the
most
um it's the most uh human
connection yeah i've had is is like
okay i i like i'm like okay i'll venmo
you
or i can bring cash but you don't have
to stand within six feet of me but could
you please just bring it outside and say
hello
and and and um i met so many nice people
i 100 know what you mean it's very
embarrassing and i did not expect to
admit this
but i i just my desk broke so i had to
get one off of craigslist
this is like a new desk quick for this
and uh uh yeah
i was this woman she came outside and
gave me this desk and
we were talking for a little bit and i
had like like nerves like it was like a
first date
right it's scary to see real people and
facebook it
is so much different than craigslist
where it's like no i don't want any
contact here's cash i don't want to look
at you
facebook marketplace you have the whole
profile of someone right
and they're queuing on theories so you
really can hit it off quick
sure you can you can you can really
you can really hit it up quick or not um
i
bought ease and i learned a lot about q
great well um
i got a problem moses yeah i just added
to my workload
oh no see one's gotta go
they can't both be in there i can't
shower this
much i can't now it's not down
now it's not two soaps it's three soaps
i gotta use up
i i'm not wonder woman
your life has has taken a real dip you
started on a high you're very proud of
this and then this broke
yeah i i i'm i'm just getting word that
okay yeah that conan is no longer
sending the new album cover he's very
upset about
the this so oh
yeah yeah he does want to invest in the
sleep hair business though
oh yeah sleep here that would be a great
brand ambassador sleep here
that's where it's at that's the only
reason i'm here pitching
we don't need a shark tank no we don't
need that people i already know
they need somebody to do their hair
while they're sleeping like it's an
ah that's a no-brainer yeah if you want
to get go in on it
with this online internet money you're
making you can
please invest in this business it's
actually called better hair b-e-d-d-e
this is great please invest please
invest please watch your stuff online
merry mac comedy comedy
comedy dot com well this is great
i know it's good moses we're business
partners now we're business partners
forever this i thought this is gonna be
interview but i walked away with
a lifelong cash machine money money
money okay i'm muting see you later
okay thank you very much bye now we have
some mvps of the team coco world
you know her as the co-host of conan
o'brien needs a friend
sotomo session is here you know him from
blackish
you know him from his very funny special
on netflix called coldhearted which
i personally i wanted that name but you
know he got it before me
and he's got a new special slash
non-special
out that i want to talk to about please
welcome sodom obsession
and dion cole thank you both for being
here
hey leon what's up family how's
everybody
we're good donna what is that behind you
sana pancho
no i don't know okay so i'm at i'm at
the largo
uh i'm backstage because we're shooting
today
and then i looked over and there's a
random like
military uniform here for no reason i
don't even know what this is
what side is that for what does that
represent though what what kind of
military what is that is that one
american's ally i don't even know i
think come on
i don't
[Music]
a random military outfit behind her
could be anything could be for any side
size probably how about this the perfect
size
fits like a glove and it's not yours
look at that you feel powerful
yes i feel like i can i can do anything
without any repercussions
boxy as hell is a steve harvey suit
harvey went to the military i remember i
wrote a bit for conan about steve harvey
suits
and that did not go well yeah i might be
giving away a compliment we're doing
oh snap so what would it take for you to
join any sort of military organization
i don't think i could ever join the
military i don't know
can you guys i know i wouldn't because i
did
uh a tv show where i played uh a soldier
and then
i always get cast as the soldier who
dies immediately
it's like coward soldier number one
we're like guys i don't think we can do
this and i
died when like you know the first part
of the show when the credits are still
rolling
like who's in the show i died at that
part
i'm black i know every black person dies
during the credits
of horror movies 100
die when like every horror movie the
credits go up and they go what's that
what
during the song during the song where
they introduced everyone
hey jack we going we going voting today
oh no no it's about me in my conan bed
the dad's moving back yeah look at you
look at this setup
you guys are not familiar diego cole has
been djing
disco mornings he bought all this
equipment a couple years ago
and then just in the lockdown i bought
it four years ago
and never had time to play with it and
just had it sitting up
and then when this pandemic hit i was
like
let me see if i can play this
next thing you know i start at
sending me records to break and all of
that so it's been going great it's been
good it's been fun
something to do keep your mind sane you
live alone
and you don't have no woman oh pets
he's the dj that cries like right before
the bass drops he
fully cries
through the music
when i first started people was busting
up laughing man
it was like don't quit your day job
like everybody was good because i was so
horrible with it but
i figured you know what if i learn how
to do this in front of these people's
faces
they're gonna feel some kind of way
because you should be doing something
with your pandemic
time you should be learning a new
language
writing a script doing something you
love to do
and while you're laughing at me i'm
gonna
i'm gonna get better and that's exactly
what happened would you ever do requests
i know dj's
absolutely hate that nah i won't do no
requests
nah not at all coming up to the booth
grabbing on your equipment
yeah objection five
and now i'm like why are you gonna come
in here and ask
to request something you just heard in
the car like
you should have it on your playlist
already why would you come in here and
want to hear it too like you love it
that much
can you play a full episode of the joe
rogan podcast
i start talking about nootropics that's
how i get [ __ ]
[Laughter]
me and timothy you silly
and you also have your record behind you
do you ever try to work your stand up
into some disco just on the the b side i
did one day i did it one day i play the
track and i play
i play my my uh my uh comedy on the
track but then i took it off because i
play every sunday at like 11 a.m
and a lot of older people and it just
didn't go
good with disco sunday fellowship and i
was gone
you see that being out sticking another
pushing and i was
i was like yeah that ain't that ain't
that ain't the most
[Laughter]
saturday night backslide backslide
so sona has picked up kind of a
quarantined skill
you picked up archery have you kept up
with that my husband wanted to buy a gun
and i was like please don't buy a gun
and so he's like okay i'm gonna buy a
bow and arrow
and so he bought like this massive
bow and arrow and all the equipment like
the wrist guard
and the thing that you put on your back
to like pull out
arrows what is it called the uh quill
quiver i forgot quill quiver quiver
that's what it is and so uh sometimes
like we just go to our backyard and we
just
shoot bows and arrows at this bag
just enough terrible things were
happening last year that i remember when
you when you were you told me about this
i
my first thought was not like whoa
that's whimsical it was like
that's actually smart archery it's
actually fun
it sounds fun as hell but if you're
using it to protect
you all you will be shot just no
just know that know that they will shoot
you
the time it takes for him to put his
gloves on and grab
his arrows i gotta chalk my hand
lick the arrow and line it up because i
know he'd lick his hair off
lick the arrow and line it up hey wait
why is tack licking the arrows he
because that you got that's the sinister
[ __ ] way to do it you got to lick the
arrow
before you shoot him you lick your arrow
by the time you do all of this and then
you gotta then you gotta like aim it you
gotta
get the aim he will be shot
why is he signing up to leave dna at the
scene
this is sick it's just that's just sick
arrow stuff you do man
a little semen on the internet
there are there are better ways to
protect yourself from like a home
invasion
you got a robbery standing there like
this like
hey i love that rash cream in your
dressing room
what did he say we missed a solid joke
he said i i left that rash cream in your
dressing room
oh that's great tell us about the rash
there is no rash he's just being an
[ __ ]
you know matt's a pretty strong guy he
wouldn't just make something up theon
you did something i would never do where
you put out essentially a non-special
special pretty recently
on netflix's youtube channel i think
it's on where you're working out
material
for a tour for not even a special where
you're like i have a half idea
to even before you go on tour you do
these small shows
that if if anyone even listens to a
voice member of mine i
think i would die and you put this out
it's
so funny it's hostile
you're yelling at audience members it's
incredible what
uh besides just like having nothing to
do what was the incentive
behind putting that out i was thinking
like yeah all that material that i was
working on for my
special that i chose not to use
it's still funny i was like man i wonder
i said i should put something together
so
i put together all this footage of stuff
that i was doing
um that i was working on that that i did
not choose from for my tour
or my upcoming special and i was like
man i should just put together and show
to people just the whole process of
of how we come up material and how it
doesn't work and how we're insecure with
it and
just these nights of everything ain't
glorified
everything ain't in front of yeah 3 000
5 000 people every night this is
40 people me trying to work this out and
show people this process you know as
well as give them something you know
that they can you know laugh at
and have during these pandemic times or
whatever so
i put it together and netflix saw it and
they was like
damn like yeah we can definitely do this
and i was like yeah we should definitely
put it
on the youtube channel like just keep
it raw give it to the people and they
was like yo let's do it and we put it
out
and i think i'm like up to it's been
probably about since october
november almost had a million yeah we
almost almost had a million which is
crazy
i i i watched it maybe a couple times it
was the first thing that
made me really miss performing live
because that's what it is
you watch a special someone has a bunch
of purple lights behind them and a
leather shirt they never wear
yeah that doesn't make me miss it that's
like oh that feels like his agents are
backstage
but when you're in the lab you're
yelling at people this
woman's like catfish
that was the first thing that made me
miss performing live man
it was genuine you know it was a genuine
it was a genuine take all those were
genuine takes and i was like preparing
for my tour
that i was going to go out on in april
and then when
kobe hit it just it stopped all that and
i just was like damn you know but
so the the tripped out thing is people
love it and i'm glad they love and
they'd be gravitating to it but
um they didn't they still haven't seen
what i kept so i would love
so if if if they're loving that that's
amazing
i can't wait for them to see what i kept
you know out of all those nights yeah
because also you're doing well you're
the first person i've seen
do well and am i wrong is this performed
in the improv
lab the lab yes okay so if anyone's not
familiar the improv
is like got a divorce and
mom's house is the main room it's
incredible there's food
and then the lab dad's house
it's mostly a bar there's not a lot of
people it's
sketchy people have nothing better to do
it's hostile for no reason
and you pulled off essentially a special
in the
worst room in la arguably the worst room
see the thing about la is when they come
to comedians
that's why everybody thinks they funny
because everybody here is so polite
and so giving that
[ __ ] be feeling like yo they
the funniest [ __ ] in the world
but you go take that [ __ ] to memphis
they will
murder your ass in memphis they will
throw [ __ ] at you that shouldn't even be
at the comedy shows and [ __ ] though
so you rice
like
so i was like man let me get let me do
the lab and
and the people at the improv were so
cool man and so i was like
they was like yeah you want to work out
in the main room i was like nah
nah and my am and my manager i mean my
agent
andrew was like yo yeah you you should
you should do the lab
and we was like fine so we got up and i
did and i was like i remember those
first few nights i was like this
is not the move and then i start going
great it's not the move because
everywhere else you really ain't gonna
be able to get the real
people gonna laugh just to be just to be
generous and
that that doesn't help you like in l.a
a lot a lot of la not la people but
people in
la they have to know that you're not
helping
when you're when you're being polite
because what you're doing is you're
setting
comics up for failure when they leave la
because it's all performers
in la in new york so everyone if it
doesn't go over people like
i'm just so happy he's expressing
himself
very rough day in my class i was very
vulnerable in my actions
i just appreciate his vulnerability and
then you go to
phoenix with someone that lost their job
they hate their wife they're addicted to
percocet
spaghetti how come spaghetti is always
too wet and people are like
no they have a bad life no
it's a world of difference man it's
really different so
i was like i want to have one of the
hardest rooms because i figured like
this
if they give me a hard time in this room
this would be the equivalent
to me doing okay
you know what i mean so i was like yeah
i'm gonna do it
and it shows in the special when you
look at it like
when people when people look at it you
you see
this is this isn't your normal
la set or audience you know this
is this is like me like
soul wrenching like riding at home with
no radio
you know oh a bad set and no radio home
oh i know that you're like you piece of
[ __ ] you don't even deserve
music
the other thing that you kept in your
special i was so happy about is you were
like why did i wear this sweater
because every time a joke doesn't go
over well you're never gonna wear
that shirt again especially if it's new
you get home and you're like just stupid
why would they put
this why would you
you'll blame yourself on everything why
did i eat oatmeal before i went i'm
gonna eat no meal no more pioneer days
who eats oatmeal
i'm a successful man
i am free to dj on sundays that's the
level of success
oatmeal and cuts every sunday dior cole
playing the cuts and eating oatmeal
every sunday 11am disco oatmeal
oh this is geriatric sauna
oh god oh god
what's happening is
ah yes
yes
[Laughter]
no oh right yeah do that lick with the
mask
on with the mask yeah it's a myriad of
reasons
how you guys doing what's up cody
how are you what you doing buddy
well you know just uh going over my
notes
whatever just grinding it out just
trying to grind it out
that's what people say nice coat
right nice yes geez
that's without doing it like a biplane
in here from the truman error
oh and a big old foam pouch
but i gotta run i gotta get my makeup on
i'll see you guys later all right
brother
have a great day love you man love you
back in there
don't tell anybody about the
ventriloquist dummy
we're ahead of you
oh my god that was horrifying i'm sorry
i was upset about how much i look like
that dummy
like it looks like the dummy i would
work out my therapy
you need to yell at you yo sona what
room are you in
there's a there's a military outfit and
a ventriloquist dummy
that's that's gotta make it on the show
yeah
lee look at that room and a troll
largo is known for its bodybuilding
context 1981.
that's sad because that means someone
peaked in 81 and they're still keeping
that around it doesn't even have a plus
i don't even know whose it is
i remember one of my mom's boyfriends
had bodybuilding tapes and he was really
proud of him and we'd have to watch
bodybuilding tapes which are just a guy
just going like
there's no action so you're just
watching a man's nude torso
sona you've been doing um well at the
beginning you're doing sona fix is your
life
a lot of things have changed since then
you might be bringing it back have the
questions got
more serious no no no no i don't i even
if there is a serious question i'm not
equipped to answer it i'm not like a
licensed therapist and uh most of the
advice that i give is
terrible so i think that you know i
think that it's just we're gonna keep it
light-hearted and fun it'll come back
eventually it's really fun to do it has
there ever been a question we were like
i can't without naming names that you
were like i can't answer this this is
too no
i've answered all of them yeah none of
them are like
a lot of them are like what do i like
what should i cook for thanksgiving or
hey can i eat old butter like you know
those are the questions the people is
there such thing as old butter
that's what i said and also i'm i'm in
the house where i'm like i don't even
pay attention to the best buy or sell by
dates
i go by smell something smells weird i
won't eat it
but if it's like two weeks past the
expiration date and it's fine
yeah dion how do you feel about that
because like the best before
sell by it's all over the place it's
kind of like asking someone in la their
age
where it's just like let's just say i'm
best before june like you can't
no way to tell the dates on anything
are you guys strict with dates that's
funniest
the i'm not i mean we're garbage growing
up
now yeah and if something in you if
there's like an almond milk and it says
february 21st and you see it and it
smells fine you won't even eat you won't
drink it
yeah i'm throwing that away really
because i've done it before
and i was like hell yeah whatever and i
got sick one time and after that i was
like okay i'm good
yeah it's like once you get sick
you've been you've been good so you know
you're gonna keep eating all those
expired things what about medicine do
you do the same thing with medicine
oh yeah it gets better cough syrup
robitussin gets better
after the day after the date starts to
separate a little bit
starts to curdle oh what's this no my my
parents are very old school my mom did
not give us like
medicine she just was like just tough it
out and beat it yourself
old school that's like the 1600s
and do some bloodletting i know so we
would just suffer and then we'd get over
it so i don't even
i don't even know what medicine i have
in my house like i don't think i have
any i don't have cold syrup this is the
only medicine
a lot of family has they have like cough
syrup
and pepto-bismol and duct tape that's
that's that's all they fix anything
that's wrong
with the duct tape for my stomach hurts
swallow a little piece of duct tape
get all those toxins out it's like those
strips
dip it in pulls the toxins out
guys i might have to i might have to
take off soon because we're gonna have
to do the
review i'm so sorry no no we're going to
wrap up soon we got we got a bunch of
stuff here
this has been great okay good this is
also the internet where no one's like
can the show be longer no one on youtube
you're one of people's many open tabs
right now
we have like hardcore porn some
craigslist they're not gonna buy some
screenplay they're not gonna finish
and then we're over here talking about
archery and licking arrows
[Laughter]
sona maybe sona fixes your life is going
to come back in the near future
i think so so send her some real heavy
questions
hard-hitting stuff i'll i'll fix
anything and then
dion has the special out slash
non-special
it's on the netflix youtube it comes up
right away you can just go to
youtube go to youtube and type in
working it out
working it out on youtube bam you'll see
it it's right there
and then check me out every sunday i
guess down i guess down every sunday
at uh on um here djinn on instagram live
and um i produced the movie that
i'll probably have to come back and talk
about all that but just
real quickly what's the movie real
quickly no it's it's it's called
it's called i'm fine thanks for asking
and uh you can go to
the instagram page and just like the
page and then
once we get the movie uh it's already
shot it's done and everything but once
we
um finish our negotiations with it then
i'll let everybody know but it's called
i'm fine
thanks for asking it's a good movie me
and my partner kelly kelly and uh
yeah we we excited about it we got some
other projects too so
i'd definitely be back to talk to you
all yeah absolutely so go check that out
and follow that page
right now support the movie you know
trying to do your own
and dion cole on uh on instagram yes
thank you all so much it's been great
moses yeah man thanks for talking to me
the first person to talk to today this
is great
love baby thank y'all man sona thank you
so much for being here
have a great show oh thank you today i'm
sure you're gonna be in it
this is a lot of fun we'll see you guys
soon all right so that's gonna do it for
us thank you for
everyone that that watched the show fat
tony
mary mac dion cole sodom obsession
a huge thank you to them as well we'll
be back in a couple weeks and we hope to
see you there
good night
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's the music in your soul
just need to lose
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
see
[Music]
is
control
[Applause]
[Music]
again
and stay
[Music]
keep on shining
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
just